háháhá o lado pessoal online explica que
quem falou dar que sejam muito bem
vindos e mais de um vídeo e alguns
estragos e que convivem muito especial
porque porque porque ofereceram coisas
que a eba virão conhecer no eu vou
explicar essa inclusão é o seguinte
pessoal a uma lógica que é ou saiu que o
saiu bem lenta na descrição e esta voz e
mandou um e mail início aos 15
marquinhos não quer produtos fruir nós
já mandamos 200 dólares em produtos e tu
vais fazer um vídeo mostrou já que tal
eo papel que é free é grátis então agora
dá uns olha eu tenho aqui puxa eu tenho
aqui sapato olha que já um sapato sapato
mas que deixem roupa também tenho uma
coisa que vou a tempo no ar é o elson
por isso mesmo até o fim
a primeira coisa que o ppe houve aumento
nem fui uma poeira vejam só o apoio e
puxa eu não sei se está fazendo barulho
o brutal país não só apoia e os
políticos e vi que minha testa porque
esta tem sido uma cara tão fofinha
assunto lúcio expulso em maio dos iphone
e do android e dois netos eu já choro
brasileiro outra vez de chorar na hora
que ela é muito gostoso
paulo eu sabia que uma caixa que eu não
sei o que é que isto é eu vou tentar
abrir desculpar eu não sei se isso vai
resultar mas todas ou o nunca nos pressa
em muniz pré expressa em um lugar que
estava tudo assim o que é que isto é
vejam só vai anunciar o pessoal olha não
tenho uma caixa vermelha decidiu que
chama-se games super nosso porque ainda
não saiu
a princípio eu vou fazer um filme com
este brinquedo tanto feito e cartoons
olha só vocês têm essa base que tem umas
luzes ok agora ligar o brinquedo que não
liga a princesa filha eu não fiz nada
temos que andar com este ferro assim a
volta destes ferrinho mas nosso carro
disse começa a apitar em vossa espera um
jogo tanto vocês têm que ir até o fim
para controlar as minhas tontas multadas
sem tocar em um ferro
esse é o jogo é incrível eu gosto o
cachorro que um pacote que eu não sei o
que é que eles vão vir aqui eu sei que
isto é pessoal basicamente está uma
cueca com um cubo de um orangotango isso
há que se falar em 50 eu acho que eu
achei engraçado portanto vamos usar esta
colega e 3 começa sem gols tira qualquer
em borba
eu não sei se isso não seria mais
olha só o que deu muito gostosa
esta é uma daquelas coisas que aparenta
ser uma coisa mas é outra equipe se uniu
englishtown action e chinelo é parece
mesmo efeito mas não é um cofre chaves
de casa para votar aqui comandos do ar
condicionado após informar em qual turno
tudo acaba aqui agora e preciso de saber
purificação tem um botão tem um código
agora eu não sei os olhos do povo nos
mandaram o cofre fechado agora não sei a
senha quanto foi que não vem com papel
eu acho que é 7 704 padrão as 777 pois
vocês têm aqui um multa um ok um botão
você já tive medo de um novo código é
muito interessante mas um pacote gigante
ou anão instrutor calainho uma mochila
de um de um hipopótamo só que o ecall
aguente é tangram poético estão china
pode ser a catarina portanto tipo é
muito macho carro
meu deus sua voz nem vão acreditar o que
tem aqui dentro o meu som
o exim gênio é mais um e moggi e do
iphone e do android ó atenção este custo
é uma coisa que ninguém sabe descobrir e
só 12 se o cara que batalhou uma caixa
cristo de y sabe o que é isto são os
sapatos é sempre os sapatos brancos
muito comum sapato muito casual muito
gostoso mas a tensão tem um segredo aqui
escondendo que entrou em um cabo usb e
olha vocês perguntam
um carro espírito que não faz sentido
nenhum faz pois porque temos novas
tecnologias e agora ficou tudo é com
carros tudo é colocar tudo funciona com
carol
eu torço pelo my files informação
vejam só pessoal siri mole gangue e
vindo da nigéria agora está também por
questão técnica que é ok agora ser
planejada bater goiás em que o tempo
edson na sola sabem que são edson busin
jogos a mostrar tem azul entender de
rosa tem peso outras 1 eu posso ter um
canto coral olha só foi ao som do refrão
represente seu nega ter chance nas
trocas suco de laranja eu não sei se eu
pareço um fã caros eu conheço mulheres
do seu preço mas não é culpa e fecho
negativo em tudo e 6/2 no verão é hora
de ir pra praia da empa china olha de
pré chuva é longe plantaram e pra vocês
levarem duelo nos postos precisam de um
quê de um quinto do mergulho durante as
outras duas têm mesmo oxigênio
mesmo com esse gênio que dentro
basicamente vocês metem centro de lucas
bomtempo dentro da água vão lá
profundíssimo resgate não vamos morrer
porém isso não deixa morrer afogado e
para conseguirem ver mais a gol claro
vocês vão por um jovem dodô e
basicamente vou ficar assim ó
agora atenção não percam esta coisa
senão morre fica óbvio subir também é
coisa é uma mágica do boxe o pugilista
que box eu não sei se insere nos vão
experimentar
olha só acho que sim e agora embaralha o
confronto pessoal tudo pronto para a
batalha ganha um só venham que funciona
mesmo sendo feita outra embalagem mais
pequena aqui eu já nem me lembro que o
clima de confronto
é uma manhã não é vocês são uma máscara
de lesão você não tá ligado nos 500
contos 500 com eu claramente comprei
essa coisa porque se o youtube não
funcionar mais
temos que ir só para um banco umas
coisinhas dele aqui eu vou te ensinar a
salvar um banco agora neste e sim social
humano ou vocês têm um erro
elton na tua carteira na mobil singular
e na qual eu subi um foco em trombone e
que eu tive eu escrevo um tipo agora
porque não gosta de futuristas é um j
era cpj arce show ex guarani estarão
proext imamt a coisa tiros nese
vamos ver no que vai dar pessoal vamos
abrir o que será que tem aqui dentro
será que tem aqui a moeda não sai pouco
vem um comando que dentro o que não
funciona por trás em pierre léaud mas de
uma vergonha lindo é gostoso olha só a
beleza das drogas
só que talvez não sofre mais umas
calcinhas de uma livre dessas regras pra
fazer ioga e uma tia onde talvez um
princípio é escudo buhr
a roma mas criticava powell jato para
encomendar está muito tempo e pronto
tenho agora a oportunidade de escolher a
temática gira vólei látex gostam pessoal
gostam do novo núcleo da uneb frango
isso também dá 11 um boné ou chapéu
muito fashion ficou aqui com a boca do
cavalo que se empenhou muito fashion que
é espero que vocês tenham gostado aqui
desde um pacs indy quiser alguma dessas
coisas uma em cada loja vai estar na
descrição juntamente com as coisas todas
que o clube passa por lá não sai barato
e menos coisas bem rápido pra vocês
deviam express tipos não to havia uma
vez pessoal quanto como as farc favorito
fiquem bem e até a próxima